[Music]
Wednesday Fani kicking off her just a
girl Las Vegas residency on Wednesday
night but the 48 year old lzd the
rehearsals did not go exactly as planned
everything went wrong like in rehearsals
how do you recover from that anyways as
god works like we got these incredible
group of people dancers and band and
everybody that's so committed all of a
sudden because there is this rush of
like urgency like okay now we got a it's
really a game like let's go and it was
it was incredible they like I was
telling you like last night was the
first time God will leave this that I
ever sang that whole entire set in in a
row
[Music]
when I get like nervous or you know like
a little bit like insecure I'll like
definitely take it out on Mattias which
I kind of like what happens like I love
when bat like I love when things fall
apart onstage to me that's when some fun
magical like intimate moments happen
like when the costumes are like half on
Gwen also let this fun JLo tidbit slip
DT there are some other famous people
that share this stage Jennifer Lopez hey
what's up Britney Spears are there any
like stilettos snakes like things in the
backstage that have been left behind my
like the other lady it's funny because I
did come see Jennifer here and got to go
in her like backstage like dressing room
and everything and it's fun think about
Jennifer we have like this similar life
and back in the day like I remember
prince said to me he's like you and
Jennifer you know like you are like you
got I don't know how he said it was
almost like he's like you guys are in
competition and I remember being like in
his limousine like with him and I'm like
what are you talking about like this is
when like it was like waiting for two
nights like I don't understand i'ma no
doubt like and interestingly we've had
some because we're the same age and we
just kind of went through our lives and
we had kids the same time and like I
ended up buying the house that she had
and like I live in her house and she put
the marble in Thank You Jennifer and
then now I'm in her dressing room I love
her so much she's so beautiful and her
show is so she works so hard on that
stage and dancing I'm obviously envious
of that and her beauty but um no they
clear the whole thing out and I feel
like I took over the Planet Hollywood
like every because every like everyone's
doing her slots and I'm like looking at
them like it's unbelievable I'm like I
can't believe they went that far with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]